I'm guard Salon I'm the ninth dean of
The Graduate School of Business at
Stanford University
I'm delighted to be with you here today
this is an annual opportunity for me to
talk to you a little bit about what's
been going on at the school over the
last year and where we're headed
one of the great things about Stanford
is that it is an immersive experience
it's the experiential aspect that I
think creates learnings that we can sort
of take to the real world one of the
things that we remain extremely proud of
at the GSB is the diversity of our
student body more than 40 percent of our
students are non-us passbook holders
around 35 to 40 percent of our students
each year are women we believe that
having a diverse student body provides
the backgrounds and experiences that
allows all of the students to learn prom
and challenge one another the diversity
here has been uh it's definitely a value
added when we built the night Management
Center we were able to build it right
across the road from the pre-existing
Schwab residential facility and what
we've learned from doing that is that we
have created just marvelous learning
living environment so we have started
the process of adding a second
residential facility that will sit
alongside Schwab it will have the that
same look and feel that Schwab does very
much Stanford on the outside but with
these beautiful vibrant colors on the
inside
if you increase price by one unit
quantity goes down one of the amazing
things about the GSB is the rate of
innovation in our elective curriculum
this coming year we will have 150
electives about 28 percent of those
electives are going to be brand new
electives this year Stanford really
encourages you to set your own course
and you're supported in that with people
who really know what your interests are
it's kind of an all you can eat buffet
of opportunities at Stanford all of this
activity that I'm talking about of
course requires additional faculty
resources so the faculty has grown to
about 117 today from around 102 in 2009.
as we do this we go slowly making sure
that we add faculty of the quality that
all of you remember from your time at
the GSP
we've made a very significant investment
in educational technology in order to
prepare ourselves for the kinds of
innovations that we know we're going to
want to make over the next few years we
have built a set of Studios that allow
us to create very high level content so
you can see this pattern played out
repeatedly in this chart one of the most
important ways in which we're applying
it in the short term is actually for our
own students I think the reason I liked
it so much was I could rewind I could
fast forward I could print out
transcripts and take them with me
wherever I wanted to go you're able to
learn at your own pace pick up that
information and then now you're
incorporating it in real time with other
people one of the things which I think
we've really learned how to do in the
last couple of years is how to beam our
faculty out of the night Management
Center into facilities abroad in a way
that appears essentially seamless to the
students in those facilities first of
all hello
we were incredibly honored in March when
the First Lady Michelle Obama on her
trip to Beijing used the highly
immersive classroom to connect a group
of students in China with a group of
students here at Stanford University
technology when it's unwell makes
geography disappear
Stanford ignite is the program that
we've been using to really extend our
reach internationally we took it
successfully to India and France last
year and this year we're adding Chile
and China with a program at our Center
in Beijing we also offered a version of
the program for Special Forces veterans
who are transitioning from the Special
Forces to civilian life
one of the advances we made within
Executive Education in the last few
years is developing custom programs
where we have a very tight engagement
with Senior Management at very
significant companies we've broadened
that this summer to Intel and General
Motors and those are examples that we're
looking forward to replicating in other
cases
we've established a hub in Accra Ghana
for seed which is the Stanford Institute
for innovation in developing economies
and we're expanding on the work that
we've been doing there we're working
with companies that we believe have the
potential to scale to provide employment
and resources for their communities and
through that to lift their communities
out of poverty this year we've augmented
seeds activities by creating what we
call the global development program
which is a university-wide research
program that see developed in
conjunction with the Freeman spogly
Institute and this year we were able to
award grants of 4.6 million dollars to
support that work
have a good weekend see you Tuesday
this year two icons of Entrepreneurship
at the GSB Chuck Holloway and Irv
grossberg stepped down from their roles
as faculty co-directors of the center
for entrepreneurial studies they have
created what is without doubt the
premier Center for entrepreneurial
studies of its kind in the world and the
lead at the GSP has in this domain is
very much thanks to efforts of Chuck and
Herb we would not be able to do any of
this large number of things I've spoken
to you about today without your
involvement without your advice without
your support and and for all of that I
thank you